Jon Stewart in his mission to satirize
the news was too successful ultimately
his work resulted in the proliferation
of the news comedy format ad nauseum a
conglomerate that has become large
enough to resemble the thing they set
out to mock let's start with news
networks they too were victims of their
own success meaning that their success
made them betray their ideals news
started out as a much humbler Serbian
profession sure it was still partisan
but there was a whole lot less of it and
it carried some form of values including
truth independence fairness and
impartiality but in the 60s this changed
news networks realized that by getting
advertisers involved you could make
heaps of cash hand over fist fist over
mics and there's a lot of nuance that I
have to skate over here but in essence
those values of journalism the reason
most got into the game they're squeezed
in the 24/7 news cycle this was one of
Jon Stewart's main premises in The Daily
Show that the 24-hour news cycle is a
system that is antithetical to good
honest journalism the media in general
you said it yourself it is it's focused
on conflict it's focused on creating
drama and a false sense of urgency for
better or for worse that 24 hour
networks are now the leading light of
our information age 24 hour news
networks are built for one thing and
that's 911 in the absence of that
they're not just going to say there's
not that much that's urgent or important
or conflicted happening today so we are
going to gin up we are going to bring
forth more conflict and more
sensationalism because we want you to
continue watching us 24 hours a day
seven days a week even when the news
doesn't necessarily warrant that type of
behavior and in this ecosystem Stewart
thrived precisely because he wasn't a
journalist he's there to throw popcorn
at the TV he's there to mock sensational
dialogue and insincerity and The Daily
Show finds enormous success but Stewart
made a mark beyond himself in the wake
of his success The Daily Show turned out
satire host the way SNL turned out
comedians the Daily Show's original
correspondence now correspond almost
completely to the current comedy news
programming john oliver samantha bee
stephen colbert jordan kepler there are
a glut of
these all daily show apprentices and
many of these have found a lot of
success which has had ripple effects
across late-night who are scrambling to
compete with what is working Jimmy
Kimmel has found his political vocal
cords and although he sounds very
earnest isn't that good timing
Jimmy Fallon tried it on Seth Meyers
show has gone political and SNL has
raised their already politicized show to
a fever pitch of grandstanding the list
could go on so let's summarize we've got
a bunch of really successful shows
making money hand over fist that are all
competing for the same eyes reliant on
corrupt crazy sensational things to
happen every day to make into theater
for their nightly shows line up all
these shows and they start to resemble
something something that would garner
spitballs from the back they all sound
the same spoken like a guy who
suspiciously worried that racist
presidents don't get statues anymore is
Donald Trump a racist I'll let you
decide yes for yourself America might be
white supremacist so in my opinion this
has everything to do with race they can
be hypercritical of political villains
and apologists for political allies
Thank You Steven that's what I love
about America you know it's the only
place where a Secretary of State can be
put on equal footing with a screaming
cantaloupe are you concerned about the
news that Russians may have hacked our
election no Hilary lies because she
didn't campaign in the swing states
Moscow it's a red state they become de
facto journalists serving many Americans
their news and they've become political
actors don't vote for Stephen Harper
exactly satire news became what they
beheld they over dramatize the absurdity
of politics to make headlines
they pander to a political party instead
of at least trying to be centrist and
during slow news days with so many
political comedy shows what can they do
but to use Stewart's phrase we are going
to gin up we are going to bring forth
more conflict and more sensationalism
because we want you to continue watching
us 24 hours a day seven days a week even
when the news doesn't necessarily
warrant that type of behavior all of the
things that John Stewart set out to
ridicule in news networks all our
failings that his own protegees have and
that is the tragedy of Jon Stewart
[Music]
[Applause]
if I'm wrong I'm joking obviously